lundi la venue du 14 juillet devraient
être noire de monde pour l'arrivée de la
2e étape de la course 1450 mètres de
barrières attendent d'être mises en
place par les organisateurs
c'est le haut de l'avenue du 14 juillet
cote symbolique puisque c'est là qu'a
réussi le pari vierzon et c'est là
qu'elle arrivera après 800 m de badauds
ligne droite et une cote de 500 mètres à
peu près exactement ici la voilà en
plein milieu cent cinquante quatre
coureurs représentant 22 équipes se
disputeront une arrivée en ville qui
s'annonce spectaculaire
les associations sportives seront aussi
mobilisés pour offrir le spectacle avant
l'arrivée des vélos
on a réussi quand même à associer
presque 25 associations sportives et
culturelles qui le jour j donc lundi ce
qu'on présente sur site et vont proposer
des animations au public
l'organisation de cette arrivée mobilise
depuis novembre même si à vierzon le
sport fait partie de l'adn de la ville
qui compte 7000 licenciés pour une
cinquantaine d'associations vierzon qui
attend de voir sa notoriété grimper en
flèche
à cette occasion quand on a une arrivée
d'étape paris nice c'est un spectacle
gratuit qui ne coûte pas très cher au
bout du compte puisque avec les aides
que nous avons à la fois des des aides
des collectivités publiques et les
sponsors privés
vierzon va avoir 15 mille euros à donner
mais quinze mille euros pour avoir plus
d'une heure de télé sur france
télévisions pour avoir des milliers et
des milliers de spectateurs pour avoir
un très bel événement sportif et bien
c'est pas cher payé c'est surtout une
très belle image que l'on donne de notre
ville à travers toute la france
en attendant et pour se mettre en jambes
plusieurs rencontres sportives sont
prévues ce week-end à commencer par le
semi marathon
dans les rues de la ville
[Applaudissements]